taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like
two fools gonna fight but only one food
can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds
hey taste buddies it's the taste buds
podcast i'm joe
and sal here how's it going oh it's
going good and
good we just ate dinner we did we ate a
lot of chinese food it was delicious yes
very delicious and now we were gonna
maybe
maybe retire today but then you kind of
you kind of got my ire well we have been
talking
uh we've recorded a bunch of episodes
today
actually over different days you'll know
they were recorded on different days
because we're wearing different shirts
and all of them
but uh we were kicking around the idea
for this episode all day as you know
from the title
it's donuts versus muffins or muffins
versus donuts
you don't know who's who and who's on
which team yet
but i will say the dumb son of a [ __ ]
that picked muffins
really i mean i don't even understand
but anyway we'll get to that i'm taking
i i'm taking the underdog today
maybe that's the case i'm taking muffins
because god you know
to be honest i'm taking a muffin over a
donut every time
a muffin i i i understand the power of
donuts
i understand the the how
popular they are and how much people
love them and and how there's a doughnut
boom now with all these specialty donut
places not just your dunkins and your
krispy kremes
but you have all those you know amazing
artisanal donut shops the more i'm
saying it the more i understand how much
i'm gonna lose
[Music]
here's a thing to me a donut is a donut
is a doughnut and that's i just feel a
doughnut is a sugary puck
it's a bomb it's it's a it's a donut
it's great
don't you can only have so many donuts
you do not eat a donut and you get a
sugar rush like you're doing
heroin and then you have two donuts and
you may as well
cancel the plans for the rest of the
evening you can't move one shot
don't listen to me a donut's gonna put
you in the grave early if you eat it
often
donuts will put you in the grave okay i
said it
so okay uh yeah i i've got a lot to say
about what you just said
first of all you can only have so many
donuts who's eating multiple muffins
what animal is sitting down all you need
is one two and three muffins in a city
all you need is one
that's insane no people eat multiple
donuts you only need one muffin
and by the way by the way you want to
talk about sugar you want to talk about
what's going to put you in an early
grave
muffins going to do the same thing but
the donut is the devil
that shows its horns which i always
respect more than the devil that
conceals them
that's the truth wow that's the truth
the muffin is soaked you just call the
muffin the devil that conceals
it it is so bad for you a delicious
treat
listen to me muffins are more of an art
form and i'll fight anyone on that i'll
fight anyone on that that's cool
okay we got we got a donut place over
here it's fair it's fair you know what
they do though
they think we don't know they start with
the same donut
it's just a donut ring and then they
just dress it differently really really
just drop and go in oil and they're
waiting on a timer and then they're just
throwing creams and sugars and jelly
powders
and sprinkles and all those things are
great and everything but if you're just
a a sugary hobo
i can't believe it i can't believe the
donut shop near the rock pile in staten
island isn't
awesome the rock pile
you don't know staten island listen to
me a muffin
is for a mature adult all right that's
what a muffin is for
i'm hoping it's for someone who's got
his [ __ ] together a muffin to someone
uh uh a professional on the go all i see
out your window
is a name of cinderblocks
just eating a muffin is i get excited
just thinking about the ways i want to
eat a muffin
a muffin is so great it's divided into
two parts
that are easy it's amazing i'll start
talking about how you can take it apart
and put it in your pocket until it gets
soft enough to eat
and and you know you can eat the crap
honestly if you google this i can't be
sure but i think jesus might have
invented muffins
i think jesus did at some point cook a
muffin and
go ahead a muffin go ahead okay it's
like it's like a cupcake
but it's worse for you no it's not as
bad as a cupcake
it's not as bad it's first free it's
three taxes
wait a minute no donuts is less oh my
god that spun me around
yeah but it's also half the size of a
muffin oh so
now he's complaining about the size that
they're not too big by the way this is a
[ __ ] stat a muffin and a doughnut
have to be judged
particularly by that muffin in that
[Music]
donut
there's only really two donut creams you
don't
what there's only two donut creams in
the jelly and then they just throw it's
glazed
chocolate but it's the same stuff before
we hold on hold on a second hold on a
second before we get into
the barrage of donut varieties that i'm
going to lay on to you yeah
i just want to see something just really
quick before we get too far away from it
pimp do me a favor look at blueberry
muffin calories i'm just
you're looking up the king right now
you're looking up the elvis of donuts
yeah what's your best doughnut i'm sorry
a muffin it's one second
hold on a second blueberry muffin 467
calories
39 grams of sugar one gram of fiber
uh now pimp just for fun let's call it a
let's call it a boston cream doughnut
the best of all the donuts
in my opinion i'll go blueberry muffin
versus boston cream
300 calories thank you very much
all right first of all what's going to
put you in your grave first you just but
you're just pulling up
blueberry muffin generic it depends who
makes that muffin you can't just tell me
what the calories are on a blueberry
well you know you're getting some fruit
in there there's nothing yeah you know
you know
you can find all those keto blueberry
muffins you think you think
boston cream donut is the best donut
correct what do you think boston cream
doughnut is the best donut hands down i
think with custard not cream
the the one with the yellowy custard
yeah not the white like
not the white i'm with you and i do
agree that's probably one of the best
donuts
it is the best it's it's really not
doing all that much it's also
it's also an eclair but don't tell
anybody
there are two types of muffins quick
bread or english muffins and flatbread
or american muffins
american muffins have round bases
rounded tops and are usually sweet
but they're also savory kinds like
cornbread muffins english is none other
than
look there's nothing all right first of
all i'm saying blueberry muffin is the
best muffin i agree saying boston cream
dough is the best donut yeah if i went
let me tell you something blueberry
muffin against the boston creams
the blueberry muffin is going to you're
dominating
you're insane dominate you think there's
a better experience in eating some
sugary crusty stale boston cream
versus a beautifully baked muffin fresh
out of the oven that just
rose to the heavens i love it you know
when it rises up it's reaching for the
heavens joe
okay and you never do this you have to
slice the top right off and you get two
halves the bottom
and then the consistency is different
between both bites
it's a beautiful hard outer shell that
then gives way to a soft
top and then the bottom is even
different and you have a spread butter
in between the top and the bottom and
then you heat that up and you have a
buttered hot blueberry muffin yeah and
you're telling me
a boston cream doughnut is better than
that all right then i'll eat a blueberry
doughnut i don't give a [ __ ]
you're telling me that a that a brush
baked
hot piping out of the oven blueberry
muffin with a little butter on it i see
what you're doing
because you're taking what you're doing
is you're taking an international icon
and you're trying to reduce my entire
food category because
my favorite in my food category can't
compete with the
donut you like i love how about this how
about this
i'm gonna go different way with the
argument you've got three muffins
at best blueberry cranberry
maybe a poppy seed after that is anybody
still listening
i know i'm not has anybody ever bought
one of those pumpernickel muffins that
are sitting there
does anybody give a [ __ ] about a
chocolate muffin nobody cares
i was gonna say it myself but you went
there nobody cares about a chocolate
nobody care really i have really go into
a
go into a bodega in manhattan at 11 30
a.m and see what muffins are less what
about cornbread
blueberry about apple cinnamon i've
never even seen an apple
cranberry orange lemon poppy seed oh
yeah yeah chocolate on chocolate on
chocolate have you ever ordered a
chocolate on chocolate muffin
chocolate chocolate chocolate chips all
day when have you ever ordered it be
honest i mean
whenever i order muffins i've had that
what do you mean you're acting like i
don't
eat or order a chocolate muffin that's
you are you you're lofted
well you just don't need a lot of
potatoes you saw muffins daily but but
you just said the blueberry was the
kinks you so you're telling
me how often blueberry to chocolate
muffin give me a ratio
blueberry's leading the charge for me a
lot because it's my favorite okay out of
ten times how many times
i honestly think blueberry muffin might
be one of the best foods ever created in
the world blueberry muffin is excellent
honestly it's not going to carry your
whole food group we're talking donuts
versus muffins
how confident i am in muffins you take
the lemon poppy seed the cranberry
orange
you take away the chocolate never had a
cranberry orange muffin in your life
you're insane
there was a delicate tested next to my
old apartment that was open 24 hours
they made the best cranberry orange
muffin i ever had so much so
that when i went to that establishment
that was my number one muffin takeaway
all right
okay so don't tempt me with a good time
all right let's go down the list of
donuts now
let's just go down the list of doughnuts
variety you beat me i'm not talking
about
you honestly a donut is for a hobo with
a bindle on a stick or a five-year-old
child
and that's about it or a heaving man
that's gonna die
soon because he buys a baker's dozen and
dumps him in his coffee
and he and he and he just he just
doesn't know if he's coming to go and
he's been collecting
social security for a long time the rest
of his family died off he gets the
newspaper he knows the people in his
neighborhood but no one's calling no
one's visiting him on the holidays
he's buying dozens of donuts he's eating
them in his house while he watches
60 doughnuts donuts for the alcoholic
every aaa meaning array of donuts never
saw him
never saw a muffin at one donuts yeah
for the for the hardened cop that's had
to deal with street punks all day
yeah yeah donuts donuts don't at your
grandmom's house
the reason nana doesn't put doughnuts
out nobody can buy a dozen
muffins because it'll break the bank
because a muffin commands a little bit
more money because there's a lot more
goes into it
has better ingredients it takes a longer
time
no it's not it's the same thing oh yeah
do you put fresh fruit like cranberry
orange lemon blueberry and a blueberry
doughnut yes in a lemon doughnut yes i
do
yes i do in an apple you're gonna go
into a krispy kreme and come out with a
healthy doughnut
i wouldn't touch krispy kreme let me
just tell you
duncan all day baby any of your uh any
of your
artisanal donut places i love the
artisanal doughnut plates you're telling
me that you don't
like like a grandma if you're a
quintessential grandma you go to our
house
she puts out a tray of fresh baked
muffins or she putting out doughnuts no
this has never happened in history
nobody's grandma has ever put out a tray
of fresh baked muffins well i'd like to
introduce you to my grandmother come on
out graham
you saw this in a charlie brown cartoon
once and you think it's not real
be honest don't lie like you do
sometimes be honest
when's the last time you were with
somebody that baked mine i don't like
how you're pointing at me
good good i was with someone who big
muffins not more than two weeks ago
really yes no you're lying no i'm not
you're lying no i am not you're
lying my sister
baked muffins what kind
assortment all right all right no no no
no no
no but banana you should chop the
muffins donuts she used to make italian
doughnuts fried dough she
dropped the dough in front of them and
then powdered that's not a donut well
had a goddamn hole in the middle so you
tell me what that is you stupid bastard
you know why everyone you know why donut
is a don't you know what donuts are the
choice because you can buy a dozen
for one dollar it's it's a dozen it's
fun are you
no no you can't i'm not letting you get
away with that i could go into any donut
shop with a five dollar bill and feed
the community
scotch scott who the [ __ ] is scott
you just reminded me of scott of a dear
friend
my oldest friend of the world scott who
makes me
this upset when we argue about food and
he agrees with you a lot when he listens
to this podcast
and it pisses me off what are you going
to say smack you both in the face
listen to me listen to me five dollars
hold on a second hold on a second hold
on a second i need you to calm down
and i need to say this to you you cannot
and i can't let you get away with this
lie
i frequently frequently buy dozens
or half dozens of donuts you are not
getting anywhere in a doughnut shop
in multitude you're not getting a how
much uh
half a dozen doughnuts dunkin donuts
half dozen is six you can't even get a
half dozen for five well now in 2021
maybe well that's what that's when we're
alive what are you doing
donuts is not twelve dollars i will i
will i will fight
a dozen ones i said a half dozen is six
you're not getting anywhere with five
dunkin donuts menu please
a dozen ten dollars a dozen for ten yeah
you're not getting anywhere with five
here's the thing
any food that you buy by the dozen is a
[ __ ] food
oh really miss nana puts out his tray of
muffins for him
that's a dozen how many do you think is
in a tray that's a dozen
there's a dozen muffins if you walk into
an establishment and you take
12 of something it's a it's it's a
[ __ ] it's
no it's b it's called there's so many
choices you can't even think straight
and you have to be well it's the size of
a goddamn softball babe and when it's
fresh out of the oven and you just pluck
pieces of the top off little by little
and you see the
steam just flying off of it and this is
crunchy
but this happened to you you have never
in your life
plucked pieces off of a muffin top and
watched steam
come out of it this is never going to do
that every time you're making
things jump i do that 100
do not you don't bake muffins you
couldn't even figure out how to work the
coffee machine earlier
you're not baking muffins i don't know
how to do it
we can we were winning one the one when
we were on the table
i heat up muffins i didn't say bake them
when we got screaming at me i never said
i baked muffins ever
rewind the taste you said you pluck it
out of the oven and watch steam escape
from it no i didn't and you could go
right back i said how great is it eating
a hot muffin
and you plucked a piece of the top off
so to eat it it's a crunchy one
you watch steam coming off the top of
the mouth okay so you're saying a
microwaved muffin is is has steam coming
out
oh it doesn't but it does it doesn't
everything that comes out of the
microwave has steam coming in nothing
that comes out of the microwave steam
coming off of it it's just
hot we will go downstairs i own a
microwave would have luck would have it
and i could put something in and i'll do
you wanna
you know what give me a favorite right
now we'll go down
right now microwave pimp go to youtube
just go to youtube and i want you on
youtube
search steaming muffin
oh jesus is that what is that nate
special
all right then they forgot you ladies
and gentlemen just just type
steaming muffin and see if there's a
video going to google type steaming off
you're not gonna get
no he's at youtube but you're getting a
steaming muffin don't get a video of it
you think dude you won't get a
because it doesn't exist
you can't not one of these you're an
idiot you can't just google steaming
and then you can because there it is
there's a steaming muffin what do you
have to say for yourself the reason i
wanted the video
that could be a doctored picture that's
why i wanted video
that's why i wanted videos you are so
silly though if we go downstairs right
now and i throw something in my my my
microwave and i heat it up and i pull it
out it's going to be steaming
i think sal i think if you threw
something in the microwave for 10
straight minutes it might come out with
some steam coming off
oh i don't think this kid's thinking a
microwave for
a microwaving a muffin for one minute
does not have steam coming off of it
steaming in a microwave lets you prepare
many healthy tasty recipes there's a
steaming version of me
oh my god joe why are you making this
very valuable
now you're arguing with me the the the
the the gay the time the time limit on a
microwave which will
uh elicit something i'll do one better
i'll do one better do me a favor
pimp i cook quite a bit this will come
up if it's a thing
how long do you have to microwave a
muffin to make it steam
type that in what a dumb thing it's not
a dumb thing who's putting that
information on this
come up how long do you have reheating
muffins from room temperature
microwave one muffin 10 to 15 seconds at
high two muffins
it's not saying it's just saying to make
them warm it's not saying to make them
steam
you stupid ass you think it's a website
dedicated to
the microwave time it takes to steam a
muffin it's so stupid
on how to build build bombs of soda
bottles
i mean yeah yeah there's probably a
saying yeah there's a steam muffin
website
steam a muffin or a piece of food in the
microwave is is
it's just insane joe it's insane not
what i'm saying to you is end of
argument
hold on let me just this is what i'm
saying to you and it will make sense as
soon as you let me finish it
you would have to cook the micro the
muffin in the microwave
for so long for it to start to steam
that it's you're not doing it it would
ruin the muffin
joe have you ever eaten a fresh muffin
that was steaming yesterday no
you've never had someone take muffins
right out of the oven and you eat them
and they're piping now we're talking
about the oven
not the microwave a hot muffin is what
i'm talking about you know not the
mexicans
said you people i would microwave it but
joe
a hot muffin i used to in in high school
in the cafeteria they made breakfast and
their blueberry muffin high school was
amazing and we would line up
and she'd pull them right out of the out
of the oven and we we break them off and
you butter on them they'd be piping hot
with steam coming off and we eat them
now if i want to recreate that
downstairs the way in which i heat it is
here no there
i'm just talking about the sensory
experience of eating the muffin the
muffin is a fresh baked
or heated up hot beautiful piece of
bakery good
i don't care i believe you you don't eat
hot dogs
muffin that had steam coming out of it i
don't believe and you do eat hot
doughnuts
you don't believe me
you don't believe i've ever eaten a
donut that was hot enough to have
steamed rice
i don't believe it i don't know what to
tell you
i don't believe it i mean i have
i can't even i'll even there's nothing
to do with my argument there's somebody
i'll even tell you steam has never
existed
somebody who actually bakes things at
home sometimes
i have never seen steaming coming out of
the oven it doesn't happen
a duncan hines cake for instance which
is very similar ingredients wise to a
muffin and consistency if you
break it open though if you break it
down it's just
hot also you have to let stuff like that
sit when it comes out of the oven you
can't just rip it right open because
it's got to settle i didn't come here
today to argue with you about steam
all right here's the point back and
forth about steam let me
let you go in and buy a bucket of
doughnuts [ __ ]
you don't shake that though it's you
don't think so
this is this is jelly doughnut muffin is
it's a chowder jelly doughnut a muffin
glazed chocolate chocolate frosted it's
all true
washing cream apple filling
apple fritter uh eclair
bear claw glazed
are you naming other pastries no those
are all donuts
a bear claw is a doughnut yes what do
you mean
a bear claw is a bear claw no it's a
donut an eclair
it's a donut an eclair is an eclair
you're calling and declare a doughnut
ask if that eclair's a donut please
and a bear claw too please you you so
you think everything inside of a
every single thing inside of a bakery is
a donut that's what you think no
everything inside
when you order when you order a pastry
you think that's a doughnut inside
you just said that the boston cream was
an eclair and eclair is a long and thin
individual cake made out of
he's wrong i was wrong i was wrong you
needed me to google that for you to know
that you know you're playing games
you're playing games with the list no i
was playing games look at them in the
camera telling me playing games
hey you like to play games hey hey hey a
cr
crumpet for instance is a circular
pastry that's fried with a hole in the
middle is that a donut
i you know what it's they're all crepes
what does it matter no is that a no i'm
asking you i'm asking you does that
count
no or a crowler i'm sorry not a crop at
a crowley a crawler
i would consider a crawler a donut all
right all right well then great okay
it's a crawler i'll put crawler on first
but you said uh
and i said i think a bear claw counts as
a dog lobster claw
bear claw those are those are pastries
there's a pastry show
joe you they are made hold on
just put in bear they are made out of
doughnut dough making them a donut okay
so can we both admit when we're wrong
please
you put is bear paw yeah i know but it
means
shape rectangular with slices along one
side to resemble sometimes
considered a doughnut well not today
no i said i was wrong sometimes it's
more common for bear claws to be almond
flavored pastries
fritters and texture everybody also
brought up an apple fritter every bear
claw i've ever had tastes like a glaze
this this this guy here's what he does
okay he knows what he does say that bear
crosstalk
by the way donate the bear does not
count and beer will never count
i'm not giving you bear claws you got to
give it to me
you didn't give me back eclair you never
had a claire uh that's stephen
donut is already the front runner in
this argument
just stick with the doughnut chuck i'm
telling you
bring it case blueberry filling
doughnut yeah you have a variety
cream-filled doughnut chocolate cream
filled bavarian cream doughnut you have
way more varieties of donuts that's not
what i'm they're all delicious
there's not one bad one there's not one
old
fashioned doughnut that looks the ones
that look like you know something you
know sometimes when everybody leaves
and the dunkin box is still up there and
you go over to the counter in the
kitchen and everybody's left
awesome thing ever coffee has been
served being the most awesome thing ever
dunkin donuts box being set on the table
after a dinner
for dessert nobody has ever been excited
by a trailer
muffins being laid out people ever oh
really oh yeah those are great points
you're making no one's ever excited
at seven a.m when you're like i can't
i'm hungry but i can't imagine putting
any sort of food into my stomach that
won't make me vomit right you're wrong i
would have to take a bite
out of some sort of a blueberry flavored
bread
that i think i could handle that right
have a muffin i'd be ready to have a
muffin at a moment's notice
ten to one more than i'd be ready to eat
a doughnut at a muffins
sometimes people drop down donuts and i
go well i
know i can only eat one because if i
have two i'm gonna go into a diabetic
shock and [ __ ]
unlike the muffins that you can eat
multiple of your muffin is all i need
but because it's gigantic sal
can you let me finish my points what is
your point the company has left
the coffee has been served someone left
behind them the box of donuts yep
it's on the kitchen counter yeah i go in
i lift that up a couple hours after
someone's brought them
i go ugh i don't even have another donut
it's this stale residue
that just got made oh stop it sal
stop it i won't i won't stand for it i
won't stand for it
sal let's talk some blue chew stay with
us folks
luchu making waves man bringing
confidence into the bedroom why
they got chillable tablets that are
going to give you stronger longer
lasting erections i mean that's what it
is
process is simple just sign up at
bluetooth.com and they have these
licensed medical providers
and they will approve it for you online
and it will be sent to you in the mail
uh that's that's the best part of it
well yeah you'll wish yeah you receive
a prescription from the providers and
then it's within days
and it's all done online i mean
everything online is better
well here here's the other thing blue
chew is made in here in the usa
and they prepare it right from here and
they ship directly from here it's
cheaper than a pharmacy
it comes in discreet packaging which is
the big one because if it came in like a
big box shaped like a penis
your neighbors would be chitter
chattering right so yeah blue chews
uh sildenafil and todda la phil tablets
are chewable i don't know if i said that
right
but hell i had a lot of fun saying those
words all right we've got a special deal
for our listeners and you guys know it
if you watch
uh they're gonna give it to you for free
for the first month if you go and you
enter the promo code taste buds to check
out
all you're gonna do is pay five bucks
for the shipping that's it so it's
bluechew.com
put in the promo code tastebuds and uh
you receive the first month free
and uh i mean come on i mean there's
nothing to really lose
it comes discreetly you could try it out
and and see if it's for you
thanks bluechu for sponsoring us sal do
you like cereal yes
do you like magic even more do you like
spoons the best thing well i'm here to
talk to you about magic spoon series
please go
guys like us ladies like us young old
all types of people like us yeah okay
they have a hard time enjoying cereal
these days many of them
why you feel guilty sugar guilt yeah
carbs empty calories
a lot of your modern day popular diets
like the keto won't allow it
but that's where magic spoon comes in to
the mix
magic spoon per serving we're talking
zero grams of sugar we're talking 13 to
14 grams of protein
and we're talking only four net grams of
carbs 140 calories per serving can you
beat that no
keto friendly it's gluten free it's
grain free it's soy free
it's gmo free it's not free costs money
uh
but it's affordable we've got exciting
news magic spoon will be releasing two
amazing new flavors this month for a
limited time only
i don't know how they do this it's
incredible they've got now a cookies and
cream flavor
and a maple waffle flavor on top of the
old flavors which is fruity
cocoa frosted peanut butter and cinnamon
and i tried several of those and i've
also tried the blueberry and they all
were delicious and they all taste like
real cereals they don't taste like deity
you know what i mean and if you're
listening from canada magic spoon now
ships to canada
so let's get let's get to the mate the
crux over here i want to get them to
discount you're going to go to
magicspoon.com
taste buds to grab the new limited
edition cookies and cream and maple
waffle
or a custom bundle that you could pick
out of cereal to try today
be sure to use our promo code tastebuds
to check out to save
five bucks off of your order the offer
is now good anywhere in the u.s or
canada
but only when you use our code at
checkout that's magicspoon.com
tastebuds with the promo code tastebuds
remember get your next delicious bowl of
gluten-free cereal at magicspoon.com
taste buds and use the code taste buds
to save five dollars off thank you magic
spoon for sponsoring the episode
you know you like dunkin donuts we've
talked about it you know they're not
just particularly like them i don't
basically
stop it i don't particularly i'm not
look if eating a dog this is good donuts
i like donuts stop it but i'm
but against a muffin i'm taking a muffin
a muffin is an adult
it's an adult choice a muffin is
delicious
i'm muffin a muffin is is a why how
could you discount muffins like this
i'm not discounting them i'm saying they
don't hold a candle to the donut that's
what i'm saying
i'm saying in the morning time you can
eat a blueberry a cranberry or maybe a
lemon poppy seed
and you're done whenever you're eating
nobody gets a chocolate muffin at 8 a.m
everybody does it joe then open your
balls
it's my it's monstrous it's like eating
chocolate cake first thing in the
morning monsterous what's more monstrous
to eat a cornbread muffin with your
breakfast with a
tea you might want to just start eating
chocolate
donuts at night when i have my
sunglasses
[Laughter]
please donut is the trash food you're
buying by the bucket
honestly any time you're gonna have a
doughnut it's a bad time you said people
won't eat a muffin first of all muffins
can be enjoyed anytime
but a muffin really if we're gonna slot
it somewhere a muffin is
in the in the morning time for the most
part you pull out a donut i see somebody
at eight in the morning
on their on their uh bus ride into the
city or something like that and they had
a coffee and they're eating a donut at 8
a.m
i say well this person's not going to be
around with their family that long i'm
gonna go back to an argument i've used
in previous episodes or maybe future
episodes because i don't know how these
are being released
but i'll tell you this you never see
this
on every corner in every major city in
america
a muffin shop no but there's donut shops
everywhere there's major chains that are
competing
there's got to buy them by the dozens
what's it called tim uh
tim hortons there's krispy kreme there's
duncan that's cause you buy them by the
dozen what are you talking about i mean
you need
you buy them a dozen at a time there's
never you don't buy bagels by the dozen
necessarily
a lot of people buy but a lot of people
buy bagel most people buy bagels one at
a time not true because they want a
bagel for breakfast or something go to
any bagel store here people are walking
in all weekend long and buying them by
the dozen muffin is an
afterthought it's a size it's something
that's there because
here it's next to the bananas look at
this
for the most part a donut a donut for
the most part
is just being pumped out like i got a
factory
just make massive amounts of donuts just
dip them in a glaze throw some
cream of sugar on them and people are
just shoving them into their mouths
they're not a refined food
a muffin i feel you need a recipe you
understand you need a recipe
it's more adult it's more more crazy
put it to you this way if if if a chef
or a pastry chef
that's this is so wrong you go to the
finest restaurants and they have like
uh uh uh what do they call uh uh
periphery uh
uh they have they have gourmet donuts on
the menu for dessert
i've never seen a muffin on a rent menu
in a nice restaurant ever ever
literally ever you you own a doughnut at
a restaurant
i said if you go to nice restaurants
they have
gourmet donuts as a dessert yes they do
so and they wouldn't have that that same
restaurant wouldn't have a beautiful
muffin
no they don't a beautiful brush spot
go to a beautiful brunch place for for
brunch in
manhattan you don't think they have a
fresh beautiful basket
you're missing my point what about a
corner missing my point all right hold
on let me see
how about we how about a doughnut hold
on a doughnut has only one purpose
you just shove a sugary puck in your
mouth and you let me
counter your point no let me muffin you
could have chocolate let me
count for breakfast
south let me counter your point you just
said
that don't you you're i am speaking to
you saying that muffins take more
artists and skill than donuts though and
i'm saying to you that's not true
because what you can find on re on menus
in gourmet restaurants
are fine dessert donuts that is a thing
you'll find muffins on any brunch buffet
because it's a brunch food you'll also
find oranges
it doesn't mean that they're a tough
food to create okay
it takes more skill to make a doughnut i
don't believe sometimes i couldn't make
you a donut
okay you don't have the equipment yeah
well okay you can make a donut
real quick if you have a fryer real
quick oh yeah it's fried dough joe
he's just gonna fill it up we're gonna
make the mixing take a ride with me to
target and i'll come back tonight
from scratch let's make donuts squeeze
it you're gonna let me wash it let me
assure you
let me see your question you go
downstairs and you make a donut and and
i make a muffin which one's gonna
taste better the muffin because it's way
easier all you're doing is buying a
batter and pouring it into a pan
okay so so take away the ease of it you
just said the muffins better
no i didn't i said it's gonna i said if
i'm making a donut from scratch you're
making a muffin from scratch
the muffin will have a better chance of
tasting better because it's simple
it's a simple recipe it's it's it's like
making a pancake let me let me set a
scene for you okay
okay yeah go ahead okay you walk into my
home
okay you're like you sit down
i say hello we've changed pleasantries
all that stuff i put right in front of
you right in front of you
a beautiful piping hot fresh out of the
oven blueberry muffin with steam
of course coming out of it sure at every
hole or
yep donut of your choice yep you would
not choose
one to one one to one the muffins right
there the donuts right there
you're reaching you're reaching for the
what type of day is it okay so you're
not even unanimous you need to know the
time
i've already said many times you eat a
muffin in the morning because it's the
only thing you can stomach that early
and you eat donuts at night because
they're a dessert food and they're great
now some people eat
donuts in the morning some people eat
donuts muffins at night but i'll tell
you this
a hell of a lot more people are eating
donuts in the morning
then people are eating muffins at night
the texture of a muffin is so much
better
the golden crispy brown muffin top that
you break open and it
gives way to a beautiful moist
center i like the bottom part of course
look they're both great but of course
you would hate the top the top is too
crispy
no it's not joe when it's done right i
like what it's best for
every world it's soft and wet sticky the
best muffin
is better than the best donut and that
is for sure that's for sure joe
the best muffin a thick dense hearty
beautiful sweet fluffy hot you keep
gaming the same question
over and over the donut donuts are
bringing together
flavors muffins don't do that muffins
don't combine i gotta be honest
if i was in a if i went into a donut
shop and i picked like 10 donuts and you
laid them out in front of me and i took
one bite of each
it it's gonna even if there's a variety
in those donuts they're gonna start
tasting the same
it's just that fried dough that stales
right away
i guess are there gourmet doughnuts same
with muffins
are there you're telling me if you took
bites out of five different muffins
they're not all gonna taste the same
after the fifth one
no come on sal no because the base of
the donut
is essentially the same the base of a
muffin is essentially the same
it's that it's that yellowy cake
whatever the hell what about that
pistachio muffin that was sick that
green one where
that's a cupcake that's a spinach muffin
too
delicious that type of stuff oh
delicious pumpkin muffin are you kidding
me yeah
i'm sure you could find look we could
name varieties all day long here
it's not a matter of that it's a matter
of what what of the varieties do you
want carrot cake muffin
jam-filled muffin just like you can fill
a doughnut yeah i mean
i could do a i don't like cakes a muffin
can do
everything that a donut could do better
it checks every box that a donut checks
but better
yes you know what a muffin is there's
more flavor muffins
this is a muffin when you take a piece
of like wonder bread
the white kind and you crumple it into a
ball
and it's a wet ball in the palm of your
hand and then you bite it
like you did that when you were a kid
that's what a muffin is basically i
didn't do that when i was a kid and
that's not what i'm muffins but all
right well
it's basically no one does that no one
thinks that a muffin is akin to
bowled up wonder bread in your palm i do
it i know nobody says that i'm sticking
with it
what do we got here wha what is that a
spaghetti doughnut look isn't it it's a
spaghetti doughnut
look look look a spaghetti dough
are there are there artisanal gourmet
donuts that are really something else
out there
of course that people stand online for
and everything i'm just talking about
what you think of when you think of a
doughnut and what you think of it how do
you think about it
when you think of a doughnut you don't
think of you know the place in austin
where voodoo or whatever where
everyone's lined up
dunkin donuts all day every day i love
dunkin donuts and i'll tell you
something you want to ask me what i
think of here's what i think of when i
think of a donut
i think of beautiful little trays behind
the counter
and i get to see all types of different
flavors and all the flavors excite me
because i see fruits and chocolates and
vanillas
and frostings and fillings and jellies
and custards and you know what i think
of with a muffin
uh i don't know if i'm regular this week
maybe i need some bran
that's what i think of no that's why i
think you brought the brand muffin into
it because i wasn't even talking about
the brand muffins
but a brand muffin can help keep
what do you mean joe i can give a corn
muffin which can also be had
with barbecue and southern food in a
savory meal no
cornbread not a corn muffin it's very
it's that means no no
no no no no no no no no it is no no no
no no no i hate when he does it
no cornbread cornbread cornbread is not
a cornbread it's a corn muffin corn
no it's or not it's made from the same
[ __ ] sal
i uh i don't know that i can speak for
you but i think that i probably know you
well enough that i could speak for both
of us to say that we are
creatures of habit that's right uh
habits are tough to break have stuff to
change
and that's what i like about our newest
sponsor noom
noom is a habit change program that uses
psychology to teach you how your mind
works
why so you can understand the decisions
you make why you make them
and feel empowered to change for the
better
newm you can you can pick the goals that
are right for you it's not telling you
you got to do this you got to do that
you got to do this over here you got to
do that over there right it's letting
you pick what feels right for you
whether it's feeling better in your
clothes having
some more stamina to keep up with maybe
a busy lifestyle
being in tune with your body's needs
practicing more self-care
you pick and noom personalizes a program
to help
your aspirations become a reality so
maybe you want to eat better to feel
better uh maybe you want to again have
more energy maybe you want to enjoy
exercising again maybe you want to feel
good about your choices
maybe you want an improved sense of
self-worth or or mood
or less stress or less anxiety this is
what noon's going to help
it's all sounding great it sounds
fantastic
n-o-o-m okay based in psychology noom
teaches you why you do the things you do
it empowers you with the tools to break
the bad habits and replace them with
better ones
okay everyone's busy that's why noon
doesn't demand much of your time they
ask for 10 minutes a day
to complete this there's a science to
getting healthier
it's it's called noom that's what i
wanted to say that's right
sign up today for a trial at noom
n o o m that's nancy o o mary
dot com taste buds there's a science to
getting healthier and it's called noom
sign up for your trial today at
noomnoom.comtastebuds what do you have
to lose
visit noom.com tastebuds to start your
trial today
that's noomnoom.com
tastebuds to sign up for your trial
today
come on dude no if you son of a [ __ ] if
an eclair is not a doughnut there is no
way that cornbread is a corn all i'm
saying is if i give you a bite of corn
muffin in a bite of cornbread you're
gonna be like i think i just bit the
same thing
you would say the same thing about an
eclair and a donut well that is a decent
point
corn muffins and corn okay people often
use the term corn muffins and cornbread
muffins interchangeably
when trading recipes and cooking corn
muffins refer to an actual muffin recipe
cornbread muffins refer to a cornbread
how a cornbread is shaped
it's saying cornbread muffins it's not
saying cornbread
go into any barbecue place in texas
they're handing you a cornbread muffin
they're handing you a slice of cornbread
it's it's different it's two different
things it's made with corn meal but it's
the same thing
so five of them what my point is though
is that you're born
that's what i'm saying now now you're
showing versatility of the muffin right
there's a brand muffin help keep you
regular there's a corn muffin which can
be had for breakfast
or very similarly alongside a favorite
meal eating this
you have a chocolate muffin which is
more of a dessert nobody
who besides you besides you and these
you can eat
whatever you want these mysterious
muffin people that you can eat them off
and whenever you want
who is eating corn who is eating muffins
outside of breakfast time
who there's a famous seinfeld episode
where the guy's eating a muffin and
waiting for him to finish then he orders
a sandwich
and they said he's eating a sandwich now
and then jerry goes you know a muffin
can be very filling
and that that guy's had a diner in a
muffin as a meal
i mean i could give you more examples
but i only just all right i only just
cited the most famous sitcom of your
time
you're right the side that the and it
couldn't be that they were doing a
quirky thing on the side
muffin tops as just muffin tops
because the muffin tops are so good and
that's i don't even talk about it
it's stolen from science they already
existed they even sell a pre-package
no it didn't already exist
it was an episode of seinfeld that they
copied because the because it was a
popular episode of seinfeld
wrong i'm not wrong muffin top elaine
makes it up on seinfeld she has the idea
for the
store that's her idea no no they that
was around before
seinfeld invent just making a muffin top
they did not
oh jesus what's going on
muffin topper australian slang in
mid-2003
no that's not slang sorry sorry when did
where did muffin
scroll up to the top the muffin tops
wikipedia no that's that's no but this
is the but this will probably have
trivia in it and say you know yeah they
became a thing after this or whatever or
maybe they won't i don't know it's
worth a try
muffin tops were not a thing it was
because of seinfeld come on you know
that man
you know that i don't i don't know look
the top hit sour the episodes of
seinfeld the the food itself isn't even
coming up
well that's that's that's not that still
doesn't prove anything
you're saying it doesn't support my
argument whether it does it doesn't joe
that's the whole point the seinfeld
writers put it on and then it became a
thing in the world because that's how
good it is okay
do you want to want me to tell you that
seinfeld created really it couldn't be
they were trying to cash in on the
biggest sitcom of all time i i hate
that like i don't like to go off things
that i can't prove
but i will tell you that it doesn't
matter because now that is permeated
society and the muffin top is a thing
anyway
okay so even though we couldn't find it
when we go through it stands on its own
two feet
in time but we googled it we couldn't
find it where we had time wise big pimp
all right let's go wow and this whole
episode was straight
debate we started immediately did we
yeah
yeah no leading all right let's go to
the tweets muffins are a crumbly mess
you can never go wrong with it i love
that i love that about it thank you
i love muffins being crumbled muffins
are naked let's see colleen's
muffins are naked cupcakes of sadness
thank you colleen
oh you're reading two from the same
person donuts how do you beat those
1980s stuck in donuts commercials with
fred the baker saying time to make the
donut
time to make the muffins doesn't have
any ring to it
culturally doesn't mean getting up and
getting things done
that's a great point yeah but that's
what oh god
that became a term for getting your work
done yeah i know but that doesn't mean
jack so let me get this straight when
it's born out of seinfeld it's
it's important and it me and it speaks
to the quality of the food when it's
born out of doughnut commercials it
doesn't mean anything no
but that was a donut commercial of
course they're going to say time to make
the donuts and that became a cliche in
american culture where it meant
time to get up and make it as far as
which is better
i'm just telling you muffin tops they're
better because
seinfeld did an episode that people come
no i'm the one who said they didn't copy
it from seinfeld hypocrisy
it's not it's just you're taking my
words and twisting them i'm not talking
i said i don't even like to put it on
the seinfeld because i'm not sure if
that's true
but they can stand on their own whether
it was seinfeld or not they exist
because they can stand on their own do
me a favor
yeah read a couple tweets before the
pummeling happens okay
i mean a donut is the ultimate treat a
muffins that thing you have at breakfast
in your hotel when you get up late in
this buffet
i don't agree yeah nobody's easy if i'm
gonna indulge in a baked good i'm going
all out
this is ready for one size girl not one
promo donuts muffins
okay how easy a decision this is
muffins are moist and beautiful and
don't need to hide behind icing or glaze
corn muffins
sal please be for muffins you know i am
bucky barnes
nothing can beat a corn mustang ever
this person is
wait wait wait wait what did this person
put corn muffin above blueberry salad
that's who's on your team right now
i'm guessing joe is arguing for muffins
because they can be topped with turkey
in his jacked up reality
you they're getting to know you right
well they're not picking muffins though
are they whichever one of you picked
muffins to defend i'm worried about your
mentor
a muffin is an icing list oh enough with
the icingless cupcake okay everybody
says that it's both
easy answers the right answer but the
right answer is muffins
good mother can actually blow your mind
a good donut isn't different than a bad
doughnut not true
still though more or less a vote for
donut
okay at first i was conflicted because
muffins and donuts are so different
but the more i think about it muffins
are hands down the winner
savory sweet can go with any meal i love
myself a good doughnut but when i want
to feel like i'm treating myself
muffins on the way you know what let's
throw back to an old episode too so you
know what goes on top of donuts that you
love so much go back
you know what goes on top of donuts you
love so much bacon you ain't finding the
bacon muffin up
okay this is a hard one i'm gonna have
to go with muffins the only muffin i
don't like is lemon poppy
there's more donuts i don't like than i
do custard filled is filled is
disgusting okay so he's not only looks
like baby
he's only knocked one of he's not only
knocked one of your favorite muffins
he's not
the greatest donut of all time that we
have agreed on donuts for the win
uh which is better donuts yesterday i
bought it
that's our winner that's our winner
yesterday i bought a [ __ ] and balls
donut
and enjoyed it more than any muffin ever
can we scroll a little more let me just
get more here you
you people are absolutely nuts muffins
are simply better than donuts and damn
near every way
a donut is good typically but a great
one is hard to come by
i agree man that's how the show works
pound for pound a muffin is gonna be
better than a donut
if you're just grabbing them out of it
it should be a large win for donuts
anyone who said muffins needs to be
evaluated psychology or
launched into the sun that's our winner
dominic orsini
dominic garcini is her winner go back
out one sec
lather the muffin and butter and it's
heavenly throw the donuts in the trash
unless they're fresh
i mean
bread-based whatever you want to call it
whether it's a piece of bread
whether it's a roll whether it's a look
at me whether it's a piece of cake
whether it's a muffin whether it's a
donut out on a countertop
in the air for hours on end it's going
to get gross if you package it properly
and put it into the box or whatever it
does not go bad muffin is so much more
fun to eat you pull down
that's not what you but that's not the
point you pull down a little little
cupcake
but that's not what the point the skirt
off of it you see the ridges
it maintains the moisture then you start
picking it off you're getting
chunks of blueberries are you ready
chunks of chocolate you're getting
you're getting beautiful melted but the
point
is you counter point a bite of a donut
is the same bite from the beginning to
the end you're taking a bite you're
getting the same
that's not true jelly doughnut nothing
more exciting than the first
you get the first couple non-jelly bites
and that one where that jelly explodes
dominic underscore orsini follow him
he's our winner d-o-m-i-n-i-c
underscore o-r-s-i-n-i anyone who said
muffins anyone who says muffins needs to
be evaluated psychologically
or launched into the sun no a muffin is
a refined more of a refined food
for people that appreciate food and
taste
the process of baking then a doughnut i
don't know i just don't agree
i think we understand i think i think
it's a more mature food
a donut is look i got 10 bucks i got to
show up with something you've said
already gotta
when i don't care enough to think a
little bit past
doughnuts the first thing is like cheap
easy fast
throw throw ten of those just throw a
dozen yeah
you're flailing right now no i'm not i
don't know why repeating every point
you've already made three times
you're going to somehow gonna win this i
understand you think about that
like royalty compared to a peasant donut
okay okay
i'll remember that next time i'm eating
donuts around you by the way the
experience of eating a muffin is so
great
you know you peel off the doily okay
break it apart from the top how many
times are you going to repeat
these same points you're going to repeat
the same point donut and wax paper
so for the rest of the day my hands
don't feel like i'm off
yeah you are such a all right yeah okay
you got to hold it in wax paper i'll
leave your hands on a sticky sugary mess
uh what and then why and then you go
like this and now your face
i don't want you to get your manicure
dirty sweetheart eat it with wax paper
let's see who won i don't care what this
says yeah 18 000.
muffins are better than donuts i don't
even care what this says okay all right
you have to carry because that's how the
show works
that's where we're at this is the big
vote holy [ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
my god oh my god
79.5 percent to
24 donuts oh
[Laughter]
dude even i didn't think it was gonna be
that bad i didn't think it was gonna be
that bad
i thought it'd maybe be a 65-35
donut in my life [ __ ]
no it's been that way the whole time
oh four to one four to one preferred
donuts
i still love you buddy i still love you
but no no no that's it
that's it let it go ridiculous
all i can tell you is i still could say
stop stop i want to say something
on how the show ends we made an
agreement on how the show ends all i'm
saying is
yeah that one out of four people
have a refined palette what i'm saying i
still love you buddy i love you too
all right that's our show folks tune in
subscribe
hit that like button on youtube follow
us on youtube at no presh
network uh no i mean subscribe
subscribe on youtube let me take this
book something i would like
to read from the victory i would like to
revisit this i would like to do
blueberry muffin
versus boston cream doughnut i would
like to do that head to head
oh i have no interest because you know
okay because what's happening here is
the variety of donuts
held you afloat you go one on one with
me babe one on one blueberry doughnut
versus boston cream
blueberry mustard sugar it's not soar
i just have a point
boston cream doughnut i think blueberry
muffin wins that i don't disagree with
that but that wasn't the argument the
argument was donuts versus muffins man
i don't know okay all right look
handle the plugs we're done please share
please share the show if you like it we
need to get the word out
uh this is my camera here i'm down i'm
sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm
sorry
all right you want people pay money for
those girls i'm not making a joke kind
of perv my dad has the same hand snatch
all right snatch okay listen
you might be watching us on uh the
youtube no press network if you haven't
subscribed yet please subscribe
otherwise we're on audio we're on
spotify we're on itunes give us a follow
rate us
share us please uh we got the no press
uh tick tock going if you are
a cool hip jazzy kid that's on uh tick
tock
uh what
instagram twitter uh i mean just
you know it is what it is uh you know
some days
you know are better than other days and
uh look you just want to point one
all right shut it down then shut it down
if he's gonna be like this
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds
taste buds if you don't want your purse
they'll take your pay stubs
taste buds taste buds better put on your
boots make sure they're laced up
what does that have to do with it
[Music]